eine schießereien southeast in amerikas
hauptstadt washington im
schwarzenviertel jenseits des anacostia
rivers ein junger gerade 18 geworden von
der polizei erschossen
der bezirksrat gibt den lokalen medien
interviews der schuldige steht für ihn
fest
die spannungen zwischen der gemeinde und
der polizei gibt es seit ich hier
aufgewachsen sind
oft sind sie übertrieben aggressiv
feindlich sie haben nicht die kulturelle
kompetenz hier probleme anzugehen
das besorgt mich die york erschossen vor
seinem wohnblock der genaue ablauf
unklar
vier uhr nachmittags war es die body
kämen des polizisten zeigt die
verfolgungsjagd die an eine waffe in der
hand
dabei wollte die an eigentlich seinem
viertel entkommen er hatte es auf eine
gute schule geschafft doch die gang ließ
ihn nicht los
sie wollen junge männer wie dion
auffangen auf die richtige bahn bringen
die konsolen eine initiative von
sozialarbeitern die hier aufgewachsen
sind wie bei einem chirurgischen
eingriff verwandeln wir hochrisiko jungs
in jemanden niedrigem oder gar keinem
risiko wie verstehen sie denn wir waren
mal wieso wir wissen so wollen sie nicht
sein
sie passen sich einfach ihre umgebung an
das ist alles was sie kennen southeast
über 90% hier sind schwarz armut
schlechte schulen kaum freizeitangebote
oder supermärkte drogen keine
perspektiven der polizei trauen sie hier
nicht die streetworker versuchen diese
lücke zu schließen
wir schützen die gemeinschaft nur eben
ohne waffe dienstmarke und schusssichere
weste wir kommen stattdessen mit liebe
und zuwendung
täglich sind sie unterwegs im viertel
hin zu vermitteln zwischen verfeindeten
gangs und zu reden mit denen die auf der
kippe stehen anders als die polizei
sagen sie wollen sie jeden gleich
behandeln und voreingenommen
sie reden mit uns vor allem mit den kids
sie versuchen die gewalt zu stoppen
sie wollen eine echte gemeinschaft
dennoch ihr ansatz funktioniert die
viertel in denen sie patroullieren sind
sicherer geworden
minneapolis ende mai die festnahme von
george floyd die für ihn tödlich endete
ein moment der so viel veränderte acht
minuten 46 sekunden unter dem knie des
weissen polizisten
sein tod hat das land aufgewühlt
demonstrationen von ost nach west
präsident ramp checks bundes einheiten
gegen protestler und dreht seinen
wahlkampf auf kultur kann
wir sind die partei für recht und
ordnung radikalisierung auf beiden
seiten ein tiefer graben geht doch das
land auch minneapolis brennt in den
nächten nach floyd tun hier wie in den
gesamten usa wird der ruf laut die funte
police entzieht der polizei das geld und
das personal die polizeistation geht in
flammen auf
eine ruine blieb zurück für die die in
amerika ganz ohne polizei wollen ein
gutes bild auch für die linke aktivisten
candice montgomery nicht reformieren
will sie die polizei sondern ganz
abschaffen
schließlich stehe die bis heute in der
tradition weißer sklavenhalter dieses
system sollte immer den besitz der
weißen wohlhabenden elite schützen und
die schwarzen kriminalisieren und
bestrafen die aus der reihe tanzen
dafür ist die institution aufgelegt
schwarzen menschen zu töten
das ist ihre aufgabe
das budget der polizei will candace in
wohn und sozialprojekte umleiten auch in
sozialarbeit das ist ihre vision von
sicherheit eine die nach dem tod von
george floyd gehört wird candace und
ihre mitstreiter aktivisten aus
minneapolis landesweit sorgten sie für
aufruhr als sie der auflösung von
minneapolis polizei ganz nahe waren
doch die bürokratie der stadt sperrte
sich dramatisch der moment als kennt es
den bürgermeister mit der frage
konfrontiert ja oder nein entziehen sie
der polizei die mittel
unter buhrufen antwortet der er werde
die abschaffung der polizeibehörde nicht
unterstützen candice sagt ihn vom platz
in denver colorado setzen sie auf reform
der polizei einige notrufe werden an sie
umgeleitet an ein medizinisches team das
aus rück zu den einsätzen wo die
seelische verfassung eines menschen ins
wanken geraten ist
ohne waffen ohne uniform wollen sie eine
eskalation verhindern wird zu diesen
einsätzen fahren gehen wir ganz anders
auf die menschen zum beispiel fragen wie
wir sie unterstützen
ich mache klar ich bin nicht der
gesetzeshüter auch nicht das krankenhaus
system wir wollen dich nicht nieder und
nur helfen
knapp 400 einsätze sind sie bislang
gefahren ein modellprojektes läuft seit
juni in diesem aufgeheizten sommer wurde
es schnell zum vorbild der fokus des
neuen teams liegt zwar auf psychisch
instabilen personen
doch denn was bürgermeister weiß
schwarze geraten besonders oft in
unklare situationen des alltags die dann
aufgrund rassistischer polizisten
eskalieren youmex mixt man eine
psychische störung zusammen mit
aggressivem verhalten und der
voreingenommenheit der polizei und hat
dann jemand der in stabil ist dann hat
man das rezept für eine katastrophe
der bürgermeister ist bei den protesten
des sommers mit marschiert polizeigewalt
gegen schwarze für ihn
begleiterscheinung einer rassistischen
gesellschaft ich will da nicht einfach
ein pflaster drüber kleben
ich will da keine lösung von fall zu
fall dies ist ein systemisches problem
wir müssen tief graben um zur wurzel des
problems zu kommen
zu diesem versteckten gefährlichen
tödlichen virus genannt rassismus das
modellprojekt in denver ein schritt in
richtung veränderung doch will amerika
zur ruhe kommen reicht es nicht nur
symptome zu kurieren
[Musik]